we're in hollywood who do we got here  matt damon  lebron  jennifer and ben  magic johnson well charlize theron is in  the house  they don't have to wear masks even  though it was required those rules don't  apply to me i wore my mask the entire  game and i when people ask for a  photograph i hold my breath and i put it  here and people could see that hold your  breath there's a zero percent chance of  infection from that how is that possible  there is a zero percent chance of  infection if i hold my breath while  taking a selfie please show me the  science on that you prick i wouldn't say  that if i didn't 100 believe it i've  just had it with these people